what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so in this video on to powerful for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I want to
focus on the black priests Doctor
Strange like the black priests version
of Doctor Strange okay so let's talk
about this for a second so the problem
with the black priests is that we don't
know where they came from I mean all we
really have is kind of like a
speculation because in reality they were
just a plot device for Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers and
that was it so the way this played out
in Hitman's Avengers of New Avengers is
of course you had to beyonders who had
created or who had really kind of I
guess really created the molecule man
Owen Reese one version in every universe
so the origin story of the molecule man
Owen Reese is the exact same in every
single universe across the multiverse
and then dr. doom had basically learned
of the grand experiment of the beyonders
from the molecule man Owen Reese in the
main Marvel Universe so they visit an
alternate alternate reality and they
accidentally killed that version of the
molecule nothing was intentionally
anyway that version of the molecule man
and that alternate universe died and the
whole universe went with it and so what
it did is it started creating a chain of
events where universes were like bumping
into each other as a result that started
the incursions now the idea behind this
at least as it was explained by Jonathan
Hickman was that the black priests were
just kind of like a defense mechanism of
the multiverse right like so think of
them is like white blood cells
it was the multiverse trying to fix
itself against an astronomically higher
power ultimately it didn't work it's
like white blood cells trying to attack
cancer cells and so what ended up
happening is that as the incursions
began to unfold we began to see the
black crease show up more and more but
they were very emag matic which is to
say like they would speak a word and
what this did is it would lead to like
some power being manifested now here's
how the words the black priests work
because this is the one thing that that
initially threw me off when I first saw
it and it took me like a couple times
reading through it to fully understand
it so let's say that you wanted to cast
a spell and that the spell you wanted to
cast was create water right like like
you know glass of water like you would
say the words glass of water and that
would basically fabricate a glass of
water in your hand the black priests
don't work that way the black priests
cannot say glass of water one priest
says glass another priest says of
another priest says water and so with
those three those three priests speaking
together they can say glass of water and
that creates a glass of water now the
way that it was explained by Hickman is
that they can rearrange those words
right select more I've been teaching me
Spanish and one of the things I learned
is that in Spanish
the adjective comes back to the noun so
when you're speaking English you would
say a shiny diamond the word shiny is
the adjutant it
describes the noun which is the diamond
and so in in Spanish you would say
diamond shiny you would have the
adjective after the noun the black
priests can rearrange their words that
way so instead of saying glass of water
they would say water glass up and that
may create a whole different set of
events right like it may spawn a million
different glasses of water we have no
real clue it's it's kind of crazy the
way it works but if you have five black
priests they can say glass of water now
and then suddenly something else or
something else will happen but the idea
behind this is they're basically a hive
mind right now that's where Doctor
Strange comes in because where you had
the black priests and each one of them
could say a word and then a second black
priests could show up and add a word to
the first word and that would create a
whole different kind of spell dr.
strange learned them all he learned all
the words so we had all the power of the
black priests now the black frees end
them themselves were astronomically
powerful I mean like when you when you
go through and you read Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers and you get to
the inhumanity tires and you start
reading about how Reed Richards created
basically a window to other universes
and you start seeing how other universes
are failing against the incursions and
the black priests show up against one
universe Charles Xavier in an alternate
reality tries to read their minds and
because it's a hive mind of thousands of
priests it overwhelms them it almost
killed him and so it gets kind of
blockers in terms of the power but at
the time that that dr. strange became
like I guess the time that he joined the
black priests he was at 100% power after
he had sold his soul now he went to go
sell his soul but his soul was corrupted
and so he didn't have 100% of his soul
to sell and so we end up having to go
back that's right because he never went
to 100% power that's I totally forgot
about that game I'm glad I reminded
myself okay so the way it's originally
played out was that the idea was a
Doctor Strange went to a place called
the sinners market and the sinners
market was kind of this place within
univer Universal it's a place where you
could go to like sell parts of your soul
or sell sell an aspect of yourself to
gain power Doctor Strange went to what
went to a spot where he wanted to sell
100% of his soul for absolute power and
basically become God but the problem
with this was that he didn't have 100%
of his soul to sell so he was rejected
and so we don't having to turn to the
the blood core I think it was and summon
like this like crazy demonic beings just
like sort of sucking people's souls out
of their bodies but dr. strange being
able to speak 100 acento be able to
speak all the words or the black frees
essentially made him omnipotent because
we're not really I'm nipa Ted but it
made him incredibly powerful because the
black trees themselves they were
basically invincible so if you try to
destroy their physical body
it wouldn't work like they were
basically reconstitute themselves using
their powers they could kind of distort
reality there weren't really
reality war purse they were basically
able to distort reality to store
people's perceptions of reality or
distort reality itself and so what you
were talking about you're talking about
dr. strange learning the power of the I
guess discovering that words is why
priests and the male to speak the words
of the black priests which were on top
of everything he knew and so what this
meant was that going forward as part of
the black priests proper dr. strange was
astronomically powerful there really
wasn't anybody I mean I would I would
argue that when he was leader of the
Black freeze there were very very very
few people who could stand against my
door mom who probably wouldn't be able
to do it because of that point you're
talking about him being multiversal
powerful you could probably make an
argument I mean it's outside the scope
of this video I don't really have enough
interest in doing it but you could
probably make an argument that he was
more powerful than the way he used to be
back when it was classic dr. strange the
problem was that back then in the 1960s
or 70s they would just have him do
things because whatever they wanted to
but when he was when he was leader of
the black priests he was powerful on a
multiversal scale you're dealing with
the beyonders you were dealing with like
the cosmic entities who were just being
annihilated across every universe but
but you're talking about him being on
that level of power and when you're
talking about Doctor Strange on a
multiversal level of power he'll gets
crazy because now you're talking about a
version of Doctor Strange it's basically
indestructible so like anyone on earth
who showed up even even like Thanos with
the Infinity Gauntlet wasn't be able to
defeat him like any any character who
showed up and like tried to wield power
against him would likely be defeated so
like there goes Dormammu there go shew
McGrath
I mean zom I would say would I don't
know I mean see that's what he gets
Harry zom is such an old character like
we haven't seen him too seen her from
zom in a long long time man which also
about zom zom was broken dude he was he
was Opie like Doctor Strange was like
okay guys so like I have a lot of
enemies I have like nightmare the of
like the nightmare dimension and I had
Dormammu and stuff like that but like if
zom comes back then like we're all
screwed we're probably all gonna die
like it'll just be the end times I'll
let you know what that happened so you
can get your affairs in order
like za was crazy powerful but yeah like
like it's it's astronomical on on that
level of power and and again that's one
of things it kind of elevates Doctor
Strange to being so capable when he's
leader of the black priests because he
has reality distortion powers he's got
vast telepathy and telekinesis powers
he's got the ability to reconstitute
himself [ __ ] as physical form be
destroyed he has a level of magic that's
far beyond what he normally has because
Doctor Strange like a brunt of his power
comes from it comes from the vishanti
but you take all that power that he has
and then you amplify it by the magical
words of the black priests basically the
power of the multiverse itself and
it's it's insane the kinda level you
have you throw him in a Marvel Cinematic
Universe and you're talking about like
the number of people who would be able
to defeat him you could count on one
hand you'd have to invoke other
characters on a multiversal level in
order to stop him so like The Living
Tribunal would probably have to step in
I mean you would see an in marvel
universe in Marvel Cinematic Universe
equivalent of like my Secret Wars to win
like the beyonders showed up on earth
and like no one can stop but he just
like killed death because he was tired
of seeing people die he just like waved
his hand like no what was it what was it
he did he was sitting in a room he was
like I'm sad that so many people are
dying and just kind of looked off in the
distance for a second it was like okay
death is dead now and was just like damn
if I'd end up taking it was like The
Living Tribunal and all these characters
who showed up to the molecule and Owen
Reese they're like you're the only one
who can stop a man and no one Reese is
like yeah but like I'm watching my soap
operas though like the other Living
Tribunal I mean you'd have to berate
like protege a protege could probably
like Protege could probably destroy dr.
strange because produce power was
infinite the gym Jasper's would be
defeated Franklin Richards would be
defeated door mama would be defeated
Chewbacca Rath will be defeated
Thanos with the heart of the universe
could probably beat Doctor Strange with
with as head of it as leader of the
black priests if we if we grabbed heart
of the universe Thanos yeah he could
pull it off because he had the power of
the one above all basically so I mean
you sort of so yeah in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that would never work
because it's just an insane it's just a
national it's it's like it's a being
with power on a multiversal scale I mean
it'd be bonkers even though we don't
really know the full extent of the power
he possess we know that like it's
stopped at the beyonders because doctor
strain was using I'm sorry doctor doom
was using the power of the beyonders way
just like waved his hand and destroyed
that version of Doctor Strange aside for
the beyonders and the one above all I
don't think anybody would be able to
defeat dr. Strange's head of the black
priests because nobody did I mean that's
it okay that's the question to ask I
mean that's a question to ask there to
do some poking around but yeah
Doctor Strange as the head of the black
priests and the Marvel yeah obviously
universe see what is destroy it wouldn't
it wouldn't even be a contest they'd be
like oh oh we're gonna go attack me like
whatever you wave his hand like
everybody in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is dead done and that's the end
of that there'd be no contest they're um
thinking on a bigger scale I mean damn
thinking on a bigger scale Wow
I mean imagine that like imagine Doctor
Strange is head of the black priests and
just like hopping around the multiverse
you could have Doctor Strange as head of
the black priests show up in the main
Marvel Universe like that would be cool
just have like have them gain that power
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and have them show up there like where
did you come from like we like you know
like like literally Doctor Strange in
the main Marvel Universe is like like
faces the MCU counterpart where the
power of the black free
like I've been where you are before I've
had your power before and like the MCU
Doctor Strange was like with like like
been at a cucumber patches is like I
don't care you know we kind of bonkers
like it'd be it'd be cool to see anyway
yeah this part we're just kind of
rambling a little bit so yeah it'd be
it'd be awesome would that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here two comments
explain make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the rob4 if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]